okay [ __ ] we're [ __ ] back okay I
don't even know what mission were on Oh
speak with this [ __ ] I wonder if at
this is going to be a [ __ ] dick thing
is great it's gonna be [ __ ] 10 years
now it is like a walking simulator okay
I like you Jesus what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ]
there we go the cat I was a little weird
and okay just do this I've been gone
went on just so I can spread your finale
again hey watch it watch it [ __ ] yeah
you [ __ ] not sucking our dicks
and while the [ __ ] is sucking those
dicks and sucking it why'd you know suck
it out wide Oh baby look at that nod
okays anyone know where the [ __ ] we
supposed to go all I know is I need a
[ __ ] horse all right the horse story
or sorry I'm looking for the horse or a
foursome to hear it
looking for horses horses horror I here
we go here we go and that's safe ok boys
let's go this way do it let's do that so
damn it I can't I'm zest for life today
you know maybe it's the pacemaker maybe
it's the cats n else you know okay okay
let's do that to do this and also I've
been debating if I should get out oh I
got my face cam you know like is it
gonna distract ya like I have a
beautiful face in here so put a bit like
this widescreen like being able to say
like everything is so nice so you know
no I'll think about it I think about it
by that display you now maybe Kevin may
be coming okay okay i have this horse
good of course not he passes it not
great [ __ ] I look right here oh great
just great I'm running ok
look at that their capacity come I don't
know is this it
say your best I'm here
ok
I am John okay they don't know where the
[ __ ] were going that sure is held out
[ __ ] hard there's another door guess
I'm looking for the [ __ ] website or
they don't stay damn look at what is
this
Oh
skinny-ass [ __ ]
we're talking a little companion okay
well I don't know where he is and this
isn't really my battle so you like
ok
the way to go I don't think I know where
the [ __ ] I'm going right she beat this
way that okay
by the almighty divine you come you've
actually come it's dreadful black
sacrament think it worked yes so it
would seem well I won't waste your time
I would like to arrange a contract
several actually okay i guess a know
what as i said i'm sure but you should
the reef please emperor that is correct
you must understand that i digress here
rexius the items rexius will now give
you two items which must be passed along
to a superior the sealed letter will
explain everything that needs to be done
yes milord is quite bound you can use it
to pay for any and all these things
right
[ __ ] weird like a little the yard
stop right there then suffer the
Emperor's rap how horsey funny yeah like
that
how's this
ok
let's do this I guess Oh what is it a
hand when I laugh at come on there we go
here we go you're back good all right
you're joking what's this life sipis
you're not joking to kill the Emperor of
Tamriel the dark brotherhood hasn't done
such a thing since the assassination of
Pelagius as a matter of fact no one has
dared assassinate an emperor of Tamriel
since the murder of Uriel Septim and
that was 200 years ago oh yeah no she
certainly wouldn't and for whatever
reason she chose to relay mode here is
information to you I don't know exactly
what's going on here if you haha you're
damn right we'll accept you think I'd
abandon an opportunity but this is all
so much to take in I need time to I'm
thinking we need and there's only one
man who can give us what we need who's
the man is in Mallory is a fence a
private operator works out of the rat
way in mist in your back good all right
so did you meet this mode here what did
he want need something until next time
show them with the dev and mouth right
ah get a bag
let's go yeah do this [ __ ] go back
back to the beginning in a [ __ ] in a
[ __ ] are we find it [ __ ]
I ordered of the yarn stop right there
oh [ __ ] i can make all your problems
with the gods go away but it'll cost you
done now move along before you get me in
trouble okay thank god
the rackets like it when I got my first
wife
greet your flight Lily guess he just
passed you on the street and dropped you
either the thick of things without
telling you which way is up and I life
line to life or the average tagging some
say so if you I can't even a few they
what after dark look champion and air
isn't it I'll tell you what that's why
we not all you need is the result a week
about come shopping unity job done well
with my shower ah but there's been a
nice thing we're out this is a tabulated
so they might be buying this an elder
kilter amulet sorry yes oh yes it don't
work up here is a letter of credit you
bring that back to your lovely mistress
yeah even if you want to better not make
trial
[ __ ] I
who the [ __ ] shower
fair enough one thing to say you've got
to choose Oh careful there we go
get the [ __ ] out of here you put you in
some money tree okay go back go back
going back going back going back here
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] Barry
[ __ ] good you're back the elder Council
Oh with Mallory willing to buy the army
splendid now then I hope you have
something nice to wear because you're
going to a wedding well Oh yet and they
say romance is dead very well the
targets name is Victoria vici the
wedding is being held in that city at
the temple of the Divine's her death
will cause an uproar which is exactly
what we want remember we want people to
notice now go and give the bride a
special kiss ok me nervous
thanks for watching